if you're an athlete you've got a five
to ten percent chance of getting a
concussion if you play football that
likelihood jumps to 75 percent but
despite the high frequency of
concussions that occur many go unnoticed
and untreated here's what happens to
your body when you get a concussion the
brain sits in cerebrospinal fluid in
your skull the fluid can help to absorb
small impacts but a significant knock on
the head or whiplash motion can cause
your brain to hit back and forth on the
walls of the skull the impact of the
brain's sloshing around can strain and
damage fragile brain tissue and in more
serious cases cause bruising and
bleeding referred to as contusions and
hematomas of course this damage may not
always be apparent since it's not
outwardly visible and many people who
experience concussions never lose
consciousness or exhibit any other
obvious signs of brain injury what
studies have shown that people who have
already experienced one concussion are
more at risk to receive a second or
third concussion over time these
injuries can cause serious cognitive and
emotional disability and in some cases
death so if you're ever feeling a little
dizzy
or out of sorts after an accident make
sure to take the time to recover and see
a doctor right away
you